the modern gamer is so much more than
being just a gamer they are business
people chefs scientists and creatives
like myself I'm a gamer that need the
raw power not only to look pretty but to
scrub through edit and Export videos
photos and animations I'm not an
animator but bless you guys y'all have
it rough you're gonna need something
that'll let you rest easy when you're
hard at work and bring the heat when
you're gaming well
we have the answer this is the MSI
Vector
gp68hx13v which boasts a 13th gen Intel
I9 chip GeForce 4080 GPU some serious
thermal management with the MSI cooler
boost 5 system and so much more in a
stylish yet stealthy design to get into
what this monster is capable of later on
but right now let's check out what's
inside the Box you're getting the laptop
in the classic MSI style pouch and
slip it out look at that that is that is
hella pretty
and of course the power brick this thing
is massive look at that this is like the
size of my face holy crap and here we
have it the vector
gp68hx13v in all its Glory you've got
the MSI dragon logo watching out for you
at the back classy MSI totem design at
the hinge here that'll lead you to the
ports besides that we also have
translucent wasakis or translucent wesd
keys in case your gamer muscle memory
doesn't serve you well enough followed
by per key RGB keyboard lighting by the
lovely Folks at steelseries and lastly
nebula blue hinges that'll make your
vector really pop look around the
exterior let's talk Port the MSI Vector
gp68hx13v comes with two USB 3.2 gen 1
and Gen 2 type A's two USB 3.2 Gen 2
type C's DP with the one on the side
coming in with PD charging a HDMI 2.1
port and RJ45 Port DC in for the charger
like of course an audio combo Jack an SD
card reader which honestly thank you not
many laptops have that nowadays and
lastly a thunderbolt 4 Port whether you
future proof your own devices for the
USBC Revolution it's nice to see the MSI
are still catering the usba devices that
we all have because I definitely need
that if you have any idea how many usb-8
USBC adapters I need to get too many to
come performance wise MSI has really
upped the empty in this year laptop by
really packing in a whole lot of power
under the hood from the top this has a
13th gen Intel Core I9 that boasts a 45
increase in performance coupled it with
a GeForce RTX 4080 laptop GPU 16 gigs of
gddr5 RAM and one terabytes of storage
you guys are a good time with msis over
boost technology which pops up the 4080
and the ion chip Within additional 175
watts and 75 Watts respectively that's
250 watts of power and calling it a
boost really is an understatement of
course we will be putting this laptop to
its Paces with benchmarks and gameplay
because what the heck is all that
powerful if you're not going to be using
it to play all your favorite games on
the highest quality settings possible on
this fast and beautiful 140hz display
with so much power being outputted you
know heat would be a problem but not in
this case because MSI has come in with
the cooler boost 5 system which
basically is a shared pipe between the
GPU and the CPU and their fans and you
know why your thermals are going to be
in check as you gain your heart out or
work with an export heavier projects
dual Series has you covered with your
nehemic sound system to immerse yourself
in the worlds you'll be exploring and
probably blasting apart or if you want
to blast some tunes these sound pretty
good MSI has outfitted the vector
gp68hx13v with a a 16 by 10 144 Hertz
golden ratio display you may be asking
but on most games in 16x9 and wouldn't
there be let the boxing basically the
black boxes you'll see as you're playing
a 16x9 game on a 16x10 screen spread not
because most games in current gen have
support for 16x10 I wasn't wearing
cyberpunk Apex Legends returnal armored
Core 6 Shadow the Tomb Raider I don't
know there are a lot of games out there
that do support 16x10 displays this
display shows the deepest of colors and
the darkest of blacks beautifully and
with a refresh rate of 144hz you'll be
watching everything play out silky
smooth this laptop was made for power
and power you're gonna get with a
whopping 90 watt hour battery to keep
you working and gaming if you can't find
a PowerPoint near you one thing to note
if you do want to achieve the maximum
voltage possible for the GPU flipping
the mux which is possible with this bad
boy at the expense of its battery life
of course so you know what just just
stay plugged in for the stuff we are
going to be running benchmarks with
3dmark PC Mark 10 returnal and Shadow
the Tomb Raider and of course we will
begin with star field Apex Legends and
armor core 6. at the highest settings
possible let's see if we can put any
sort of load and strain on the vector
with it being plugged in of course MSI
has put in four settings for power super
battery silent balance and Extreme
Performance which we will of course be
using so now let's run through the
results again we will be running all
these benchmarks and gameplay with the
charger plugged in for 3D Mark the score
for time spy extreme is 9141 we also ran
fire strike extreme and that's got 21
288 and just for fun we ran through fire
strike Ultra and that scored 11 279 PC
Mark 10 scores we have 11 031 for
Essentials
9923 for productivity and digital
content at 10
671 and the overall PC Mark 10 score is
7000 and 550. the returnal benchmarks
came back with an average of 135 FPS
with a maximum of 214 FPS at the highest
settings possible the shadow of the Tomb
Raider benchmarks came back with an
average of 153 FPS on the high settings
and we will be showing the rest of the
results on the screen right now running
MSI After Burner to track our
performance playing Star field we hit an
average of 71 FPS and a maximum frame
rate of 145.3 FPS and it runs smoothly
there are only sharp drops in
performance when swapping weapons out
but that's probably due to the fact that
the game is not completely optimized for
laptop gpus like the 4080 and of course
the 13 gen I9 Intel CPU that we are
running right now other than that combat
feels very smooth in space and on the
ground Apex Legends played buttery
smooth at an average of 171 FPS and a
maximum of 300 FPS having that 144
display really helps you get a slight
advantage over your opponents unless you
suck like I do at least your death to
look pretty our core 6 has 620 FPS
option and that's great for me from
software game I'll play through had an
average of 59 FPS and a maximum of 144.8
FPS the feel of playing on the keyboard
with an agile AC built felt very natural
the keycap sizing is big enough so you
won't miss a beat in your gaming flow
and yes I did beat beltius premium patch
as well took me like 20 tries it is very
safe to say that the vector
gp68hx13v will be the perfect companion
for the professional on the go who needs
the raw power to game and work wherever
and whenever in the world and yes it
definitely has a massive power brick but
that's only to juice up the lean
portable gaming machine that it is it's
got great scores coming through the
games that we played in the benchmarks
we run through so honestly if you're
looking for upgrade for your current
gaming laptop or you're looking to try
one out I think the vector gb68x13
great place to start or continue that's
it for this video we hope you've enjoyed
it let us know what you think about the
MSI vector
gp68hx13v and if you have any questions
leave them down in the comments below
and we'll do our best to get to them for
more info on this laptop check out links
in the description below MSI has more
laptops for every price point so do
check that out until next time
foreign